aj i am so excited that the bravest
night is coming to canada finally this
is the show
this is a show that we need so much but
i have an idea that when they approached
you and said hey aj would you like to
voice a fairy in the show that you were
like hell yeah is that what your
response uh
pretty much yes um you know once i once
i knew exactly what the story was what
the characters were
there wasn't i didn't even bat an eye i
was like sign me up
um and i and i i i'm a huge and like
animated
you know tv shows or films i love
animation so much um even before i
became a father like
a grown man watching cartoon network
like i have no shame okay i love
cartoons um so to be asked to be a part
of a a cartoon and be a cartoon with
with
such an amazing story at the epicenter
and so much inclusivity um
and the first
animated gay couple
uh you know on a on a kids tv show i'm
like this is this is incredible this we
need more of this
um
you know so
yeah and once they told me about my
character i was like
i love this he's this grumpy he's a
grumpy fairy who doesn't want to get up
in the morning but has a big heart
and
and is kind of a mentor you know he the
character kind of reminds me a little
bit of
of like owl from winnie the pooh like
owl was that
you know kind of overseer of
the briar patch you know so
yeah definitely listen aj you're a
father you have two children is
educating your children i i'm a queer
person out loud and proud i did not grow
up with this kind of content in front of
me and that's why it makes me so happy
that children today do have this kind of
content as a father of two is it super
important for you to kind of
show them the beauty of the world the
diversity of the world the love in the
world and the awesome 100
100
like um you know my
my wife and i um
are we have a very
a very open relationship and honest
relationship with our children
um we don't
filter anything
we don't uh hold back if there's
questions
um
you know
if my kids asked me why are those two
men holding hands
the the short and easy answer is because
they love each other yeah it it it
doesn't have to go past that um
you know and
i
even so much to the point
years ago i got ordained online yeah
uh to marry my two best gay friends and
it was a blessing and a curse blessing
because i got to do something so sweet
and so cool for my two best gay friends
the drawback was now all my other
friends that want to get married want me
to be there and and i'm like no no no
this was special for my friends uh i i
also didn't realize once you get
ordained online you're ordained
indefinitely oh yeah i i i so i'm like
well cool you know but
no i mean we you know we've we've been
very open with our children and um
it's
it's such a it's such a beautiful thing
and i wish more people would be this way
but
i'm excited that you know this is kind
of the first of its kind
um and i hope that this sets a domino
effect for more
more children shows more education
on the lgbtq community because again
we're all
we're all the same man we're all cut
from the same cloth we all bleed the
same we put our pants on the same some
tighter than others but we all put our
pants on the same i wear very tight pins
um so you know i mean
i'm honored to be a part of this so
yeah i'm gonna be uh totally honest with
you aj like growing up
bsb backstreet boys
was a bit of like a queer awakening for
me because i had a lot of um girlfriends
like in grade school and high school and
they'd be flipping through these pages
of like bop magazine and those
things right and like
i
saw backstreet boys and i was kind of
like okay that was when i started to
realize that maybe i was a bit different
maybe i was you know into guys and not
girls and you specifically i don't want
to make this awkward between us but you
specifically i always connected with
because you were you had this uh you
weren't a cookie cutter you had your own
vibe you had your own style and i really
connected with you because of that so aj
was always my favorite just like thank
you
you're welcome but did you did you know
at that time aj that you had a queer fan
base and that people really with the
community from that community felt so
connected to you
um
i did uh you know um
i really did when when we were asked to
do pride
years ago in the in the bay area in san
francisco
um
and
we were riding in the back of this
convertible cadillac
um
and
the the overwhelming support
from the gay community i was just like
this is rad number one
and
i grew up in musical theater i grew up
around the gay community my whole life
my old acting teacher
who is still near and dear to my heart
um
was the first time i saw
two women as
partners i didn't know what it was i
asked my mom and she told me and i was
like cool all right that's awesome
and i just
looked at all of this as
people loving each other and it doesn't
matter if
two are the same or two are different it
doesn't matter love is love and love is
love should be blind should be
um
to both gender and race uh but i think
for me
also being very comfortable with my
sexuality be very comfortable in my own
skin
i've i mean i i'm wearing makeup right
now i've been wearing nail polish i used
to wear eyeliner
i've worn dresses before i
you know i wore a dress at my wedding i
wore six-inch heels at my wedding
uh which let me tell you
a lot of the women at the wedding were
very mad that i could rock six-inch
louboutins better than they could and
dance in them by the way
um but yes i i am i am honored to be
a part and a huge advocate for the lgbtq
community it's
you know
i what can i say i love my gays man i do
i i freaking do
um this is my new favorite shirt that i
got by the way oh that's incredible i
love it i know
yeah so i'm
yeah i'm i'm stoked this is this is
this has been a great journey and you
know now especially
you know 28 years later cut to where
backstreet boys are now yeah we've all
become
very individualized where people know us
for art for who we are
individually so now i get to really
express
my
support and my gratitude for the lgbtq
community for their support of me and
them and and their and the fellas and my
support back
so yeah well the community loves you aj
and that support is imperative and it is
so important for so many people out
there your latest single in video love
song love is just kind of like another
huge love letter to the lgbtq plus
community and specifically to the
transgender community um why was it
important to include such a powerful
message in that latest video
um you know when i
when i finished recording the song
um i was i'll never forget i was in my
car
with my partner renee lozando who is my
directing partner we've directed two
solo videos from me we co-directed the
backstreet boys chances video uh it's
the first time a backstreet boy has
directed a backstreet boy video
um
and
we were i i was playing in the song
and
i i was just talking out loud and i'm
like you know what
i want
to have
two beautiful women
featured in this
video
and he was like okay cool cool and i
said yes but
but i want them to be two beautiful
transgender women
i said because
i i i the song to me is just about
everybody wants that love song love
everybody wants the storybook love
and everyone deserves the storybook love
everyone
so
once and and and he's also a massive
supporter as well so then he sends me
photos of the location that we ended up
shooting at which again looks like
barbie exploded everywhere
and no one's ever used this location for
a music video which blows my mind
um and i was like okay this is just a
match made in heaven and both nala and
carmen
two beautiful women they were so amazing
on set and
that i i i i do hope i get to work with
them again which i am planning on at
some point
um you know to continue the story there
is going to be
an underlying story through all of my
solo music moving forward and it's going
to
continue to be
inclusivity so
uh expect more
like that and maybe even even more um
you know i'm already going through my
head about the next single and the next
video treatment
there will be a lot of
both gay straight
transgender there's going to be a lot of
that in the video
um
it's going to be yeah i don't want to
give any more away no it's going to be
it's going to be pretty incredible
i'm excited i can't wait uh is there
like a dream collab for you aj with your
solo music because i would love to see
you team up with somebody like uh one of
my favorites is kim petras right now
like kim is
incredible kim is incredible um i think
for me a lifelong dream
uh
i know her as alicia everyone knows her
as pink
um
for me to do something with pink would
be
because because both of us have that
edge we've dyed our hair the tattoos and
we're both massive support
so i think
we could do something pretty incredible
um
and or
why not you know something else i
thought that could be cool
is
like a almost like a we are the world
type of a song type of event and get a
lot of both
the lgbtq community and the straight
community but massive support from the
straight community and put us all
together and let's
let's make something magical
i think that could be
i mean it's never been done
so
that is a great idea
i'm telling you i think i mean look
it's all
we're we're on the uphill climb right
now oh yeah and
because let's face it the last four
years
not so good
um so uh and we're on the uphill right
now and i am honored to be a part of the
uphill climb
because
it's long overdue it just is i mean
every you know all the negative nancy's
need to just shut their mouth just go
away go to sleep go to sleep
i'm with you on that aj finally i don't
want to take up too too much of your
time but listen backstreet boys released
their latest album 2019 dna it was a
huge hit it debuted at number one in the
u.s and right here in canada it was a
huge hit here in canada
um did that album really remind yourself
and the rest of the band that
people have an appetite still for
backstreet boys you know when you've
been doing this for such a long time
sometimes you forget that there is this
huge massive audience out there i mean
we have honestly we call our fans the
backstreet army for a reason they will
fight for us they will stand beside us
in the trenches they've been with us
from day one
um and
this is one of my most proudest records
i think we've done because
um
even though i came up with the title
i'm i'm just gonna plug that for myself
but the reason being is because
the body of work on the dna album is the
dna of the backstreet boys it is what
makes us
who we are um and the live show is
incredible we are anxious to get back on
tour
um and i know we're coming back to
canada so i'm excited about that
um
you know canada's always been like a
second home to me
um
you know it's because of you guys
that the u.s even knew who we were
everything started for us in europe then
it went to france france leaked into
the french-speaking quebec and then
leaked down into new york and the rest
is history yeah but um yeah i mean look
i i am i am honored and proud of this
record and
we finally have a christmas album after
28 years it's insane it took us this
long
but i promise you
i promise you this
from my mouth to god's ears
it's worth the wait trust me on that
you